herzlich willkommen bei jetzt reden wir
heute mit natascha ochsenknecht ja ich
freue mich dass hier schon dass du da
bist dass du dir zeit genommen hast ja
unbedingt in so einer tollen runde
unser erstes thema heute der
schreckliche fall aus münster
der missbrauchsfall in münster hier soll
der 27-jährige it-techniker adrian v mit
anderen männern mehrere jungen im alter
von fünf bis zwölf jahren gequält und
vergewaltigt haben
bilder und videos davon hatte er im darf
nicht verkauft
wenn du diese bilder sie es lieber
natascha und die ganzen
berichterstattung ließ und verfolgt die
ganz besonders in der letzten woche sehr
geballt vorhanden sind wie geht es dir
damit was fühlst du dann ist natürlich
für mich als mutter oder als betroffene
mutter eben auch ein schlag ins gesicht
weil ja der menschen über opfer urteilen
und das anscheinend ich nachvollziehen
können dass man das im abtut und sagt
das ist ein vergehen zum beispiel und
kein verbrechen das immer wieder
bewährungsstrafen erfolgen und dass die
täter auch nicht ins gefängnis kommen
dann dass man sagt na ja gut er macht
jetzt die therapie das wird schon wieder
dass die opfer im prinzip im gewissen
rahmen auch angehört werden müssen und
nicht vorgeführt werden
also das sind so ganz viele pakete oder
ich natürlich dann sehe wie viel darum
geschlampt wird dass da auch anrufe
getätigt wurden dass da eben an scheint
irgend etwas nicht ganz koscher ist und
man da irgendwie dem ganzen nicht
nachgeht ob das jugendamt ist gehören
oder polizei das ist abgetreten abgetan
wird dann ist das natürlich ganz
schrecklich wo ich jetzt auch gesagt
habe so jetzt aktiv mache ich da mal
aktiv auch ein bisschen mit und gucke
mal das paar gewisse dinge passieren
aber was was geht also was geht in einer
mutter vor wenn sie erfährt dass der
sohn missbraucht wurde das ist ja eine
eine vorstellung die ich mir selbst als
zweifach mutter überhaupt nicht ausmalen
möchte mir sofort die tränen kommen
du bist jetzt sehr sehr aktiv aber es
gab bestimmt auch eine andere zeit
erzählen es davon jede dame ja für mich
also wenn man sowas als mutter erfährt
oder als vater oder als familie ist das
einfach das ist ein stich ins herz
und das wird auch nie wieder heilen weil
du natürlich also anfängst hier vorwürfe
zu machen
jetzt muss man dazu sagen man tut
natürlich alles um seine kinder zu
beschützen und ich sage jetzt etwas was
vielleicht ganz schön
wir können nicht alle kinder beschützen
so fängt ja schon mal an egal was du
tust du kannst dein kind nicht
hundertprozentig beschützen hast du die
vorwürfe gemacht dass du erfahren hast
du deine ältester missbraucht wurde
natürlich habe ich mir vorwürfe gemacht
aber letztendlich hat sie bei mir sofort
der schalter umgelegt und ich habe mir
gedacht jetzt muss sie aktiv werden
ich muss den täter ins gefängnis bringen
was ich ja gott sei dank auch geschafft
habe aber ich muss dazu sagen auf eigene
recherchen
die polizei hat erstmal gar nichts
gemacht wie hast du es denn erfahren ich
habe es mir gedacht dass er irgendwas
ist ich war aber gerade im ausland und
parallel war eine freundin von mir zu
hause mit den beiden kindern weil wir
für zwei und ausland mussten
und meine mutter war auch da also von
daher war das alles fein das hat sich
eigentlich parallel ergeben dass ich
dachte wenn ich zurückkomme tier kommt
nicht mehr zu meinen kindern und das
waren ja auch nur dinge also du bist ja
auch freunde zu hause haben und sagt
mensch kann es mal kurz auf die jungs
auf partie beim einkaufen so war das und
er rechnet nicht damit und es ist 80
prozent sind immer aus dem näheren
umfeld nach 20 prozent ist ein fremder
der dann kommt und irgendwas tut 80
prozent ist familie bekannte freunde der
nachbarn und die ich erschleichen sich
das mit den kindern das verhältnis also
dass man sagt nicht wie geht der kann
vielleicht ein tier oder wird man die
katze streicheln oder so das wird alles
so spielerisch gemacht die sind ja
teilweise so was von schlau wie das
angehen und deshalb man kann sein kind
aber man kann zusehen dass die fälle und
die täter viel schneller als tageslicht
kommt dass man durch und genau das hat
er gemacht du hast durchgegriffen du
bist nicht einfach alle tage stehen
geblieben und was natürlich war so
schockiert aber du hast dich davon nicht
dominieren lassen weil ich persönlich
extrem bewundernswert finde ich war
norbert und dann hast du einfach jemand
funktioniert dann wahrscheinlich um ihn
ins gefängnis gebracht
wie macht man ja nicht selbst ins
gefängnis gesteckt wie macht man sowas
welchen weg geht man sich fragt nur weil
ich finde das ist ein thema man weiß ja
gar nicht richtig was man machen soll
wie verhält man sich richtig was was
macht man was hast du ganz persönlich du
gemacht ich hab ihr zugang zu seinen ja
ich habe mir zugang zu seiner wohnung
verschafft er war noch im ausland und
ich habe mir unterlagen besorgt und hab
dann herausgefunden
das muss man sich mal vorstellen er war
elf mal vorbestraft auf bewährung wie
kindesmissbrauch
es gibt hier das risiko eines gang ist
wusste ich gar nicht natürlich nicht und
da fragt man sich wer ist als jahr mein
ex-mann hat damals einen jahren die
filmproduktion waren mit der
filmproduktion unterwegs auch im ausland
und das war damals der lebensgefährte
von dem filmproduzenten motorrad selber
mann ist am set dreht man ist
zusammenhang ist die familie war ich
habe gekocht für alle
so war das ja also es gab ja noch nicht
mal so dass er haye hat auf die kinder
aufgepasst erkenne mich überhaupt nicht
ich bin mal eben die dusche oder kannte
ich gehe mal kurz zum einkaufen so
passiert ist
und ja ich habe das dann selber alles
rausgefunden haben recherchiert das
würde jetzt den rahmen sprengen war sehr
viel arbeit aber ich habe es tatsächlich
geschafft druck aufzubauen mit meinem
anwalt
ich habe mich mit den behörden so ein
bisschen angelegt mit der polizei und
habe gesagt entweder urlaub oder ich
bringe das jetzt sofort an die presse
dass da einer ist der elfmal bewährung
hatte das problem ist dass diese täter
oft auf mitleid machen und sagen sie
sind selber missbraucht worden und das
als schutz für sich nehmen oder als
freifahrtschein oder gegeben ein
teilgeständnis ab das heißt es tut mir
so leid und so dann sitzt da einer mit
einem hemd und einer brille und der
richter sagt mein gott der armen hat es
selber erlebt und habe schon das problem
dann geht es mal ganz schnell auf einer
bewährung hinaus nur pech hat jetzt hast
du da sehr sehr stark und hast da
wirklich dann stiefel selbst seit
durchgezogen wenn du das jetzt aber
immer wieder hört das konto immer so in
wellen hoch finde ich ja jetzt reden
miteinander wochen ganz ganz viel drüber
und wir alle hoffen jetzt natürlich ganz
toll dass sich endlich was ändert und
dass man nicht das wieder so im sande
verlaufen lässt das ist ja unsere größte
angst was vor dass du ganz konkret als
betroffene man keine bewährungsfrist mir
dass man sagt es ist ein schweres
verbrechen und kein vergehen dann
natürlich dass diese kinder dann auch an
die hand genommen werden und die
familien dass sie die betreut werden
also ich zum beispiel das hört sich
jetzt auch ich habe viele krimi bücher
gelesen
das hat mir in dem fall wo man denkt hey
wie jetzt krimiserie hat mir sehr
geholfen dass ich meine kinder die worte
mein kind die worte nicht in den mund
gelegt haben
also man darf zum beispiel nicht franck
hat er das und das gemacht hast du schon
probleme mit mittätern hören wo man das
hat ja dem kind in mund
gegner schwierig also du musst gucken
dass du mit deinem kind so umgehst dass
er tatsächlich auch diese straftat
nachgewiesen werden kann
kinder musik erinnern war das jetzt im
frühling war darf an einem bestimmten
ort welcher tag war das kann ein kleines
kind aber auch noch nicht da muss man
auch wider abwägen also das kind muss
behütet befragt werden da gibt's zum
beispiel child childhood da bin ich
jetzt dabei die haben häuser gebaut wo
die kinder angehört werden wo die
familien betreut werden wo das ein
rahmen ist wohl auch kein kind keine
angst haben muss weil diese anhörung
sind ja teilweise sehr brutalen also
dass man damit den kindern besser umgeht
und mit den familien mit der betreuung
und anhörung das ist mir ganz wichtig ja
und dass man das ganze immer ernst und
auch mal sagt lieber einmal mehr zwei
spiele bei den behörden offenbar der
polizei wenn man einen verdacht hat als
zu schweigen
also wir sehen ja in diesem ganzen
gartenhäuser wasser überall passiert das
ist die heile welt die leute können mir
nicht erzählen wenn das nicht
irgendetwas vielleicht auch auffällig
war
genau deswegen finde ich so wichtig und
so mutig auch das ist auch betroffene
darüber sprechen weil wie du selber ist
mutter hat man ein schlechtes gewissen
man hat auch ein schlechtes gewissen bei
verdachtsmomenten mal nachzufragen man
kennt sich und man schämt sich die
kinder denen es passiert die schämen
sich und wissen nicht wie sie sich auch
da sind wir auch als gesellschaft
gefragt ich als mutter bin gefragt ich
bin meinem sohn ganz klar bei dass es
sein körper ist der rs5 und trotzdem
lernte er ohne dass ich ihm damit angst
machen möchte oder schreckensszenarien
aufbauen möchte lernt er dass er grenzen
setzen darf und das ist total okay so
das fängt an bei ich will nicht dass die
oder dem ihr ein küsschen auf die wange
gibt ja gemeinden körper und ich möchte
das nicht so wäre hätte ich also dass da
hast du völlig recht das war bei unseren
kindern natürlich auch immer so das
problem war nur wenn da einer kommt mit
dem du über längeren zeitraum zusammen
bist wie eben ein freund der familie ja
der daraus ja du vertraust und das
problem ist zum beispiel bei mir gewesen
ich war vorher frisch operiert ich bin
fast gestorben
und dann kommt ein täter also in dem
fall der freund und sagt wenn du das
jetzt seine mama erzählt
da muss die leider töten gerade kinder
oft sagen was mich nicht an in dem
moment weiß der mutter frisch operiert
und dann sagt das kind nichts das heißt
du musst solche antennen deshalb ist es
unheimlich schwer
aber allein wer der täter nicht so oft
mit bewährungsstrafen davon gekommen
wäre das ja gar nicht hättest ja gar
nicht so weit gekommen
läuft der noch frei rum auch ich habe in
dreieinhalb jahre im knast lange apropos
sein was was muss sich politisch ändern
also zunächst einmal riesenrespekt also
auch davor dass du dieses schweigen
gebrochen hast du ja das unrecht was
beschwiegen wird wird nun noch größer
und das hilft in erster linie den tätern
und insbesondere wenn es die eigenen
familienverhältnisse betrifft ich glaube
das ist wirklich eine leistung die
beispiellos ist und ich finde es schön
dass du uns mal heißt rein gucken lassen
was bedeutet das eigentlich auch als
mutter sozusagen in dem fall das gefühl
hat nicht schützen zu können obwohl man
gar nichts dafür kann und ich glaube was
ganz wichtig ist es zu realisieren dass
wir alle als gesellschaft versagt haben
ich frage mich echt gerade was in
unserem land los ist wenn ich sowas lese
und ich krieg herzklopfen ich krieg ein
flaues gefühl im magen
und es ist wirklich eine traurige bilanz
dass wir als gesellschaft versagen und
dann ja erst das jugendamt zum tragen
kommen wenn alles andere nichts mehr
hilft und die 2
allein die tatsache dass missbrauchs
kinder die von missbrauch betroffen sind
mit sieben erwachsenen reden müssen um
überhaupt erst mal ernst und
wahrgenommen zu werden
das ist doch schon eine armuts erklärung
und ich glaube man muss aus diesem fall
gehen ganz klar ein verbrechen machen es
stellt sich hier die frage der
unverhältnismäßigkeit wie kann es sein
dass man nach drei mal schwarz fahren
wenn man nicht bezahlt dann ins
gefängnis muss aber als sozusagen
triebtäter ab so die möglichkeit hat
noch mal so eine straftat zu begehen und
den kindern damit lebenslänglich zu
verpassen das kann man niemandem
erklären also die haftstrafe muss auf
jeden fall verschärfen dass es keine
frage was gibt es noch was was was sind
noch punkte auf der liste will sagt das
muss sich ändern sonst ändert sich gar
nichts also ich glaube es geht in der
tat um das bewusstsein als
menschenrechtsaktivistin habe ich auch
mit vergewaltigungsopfern zu tun ist
trifft nicht nur die person die
missbraucht wird sondern eine ganze
familie das thema ist scham behaftet
das fängt schon an meinem begriffe
kinderschänder also ich finde nicht dass
man den kindern sprachlich die schande
zu schieben muss denn ein kind kann
nichts dafür
also da aus und bei den
begrifflichkeiten aufzupassen aber eben
auch in dem fall wo das passiert auch
zivilcourage verantwortung zu übernehmen
und letztlich das auch anzuklagen und
seinen gefühl seiner intuition auch zu
folgen weil ich glaube aber mutter
tut man das was man auch gleich mal
sagen sollte man denkt immer so wie herr
kindesmissbrauch das sind ja nur so
sozial schwache familien oder so nein
überhaupt nicht dass es überall und man
sieht es ist ein lehrer das ist sind es
ja überall also das ist überall gibt es
diese fälle und man musste einfach
durchgreifen und der einzige lange arm
der da ist das ist die politik und wenn
die das nicht auf die reihe kriegen und
jemand der steuern hinterzieht der muss
für fünf jahre in kraft ja und dann
einer der sich an kindern vergeht da
sagt man ja der hat jetzt mal macht
diesmal gerade in die therapie das wird
schon ne ist nicht nehmen also in unna
preise aus der er hat im stuhlkreis
gesetzen therapie gemacht und hatte bis
zu einer strafe abgesehen ist ja der hat
jetzt mal kapiert und wo war er wieder
am bahnhof hat sich die stricher hoya
und genau das ist der punkt das wissen
müssen jetzt auch langsam kapiert haben
alle dass das nicht funktioniert wir
schreiben auch ganz viele betroffene
eltern viele betroffene mütter was ist
da was ist das der hauptpunkt denen die
fordern bzw wo ist das größte
unverständnis wo fängt es an
er ist es natürlich dass ich viele sehr
schämen sehr schlimm und dass ich es
gemerkt haben dass es teilweise auch der
vater ist also ich habe selber nicht
meine freundin wurde von ihrem vater
missbraucht ganz schlimm katholische
familie sage ich nur ganz krass also nur
beten jeden sonntag in der küche und
dann na sowas also dass die eltern eben
sich nicht trauen dass sie nicht wissen
an wen sie sich wenden sollen weil das
kind vielleicht auch 12 13 schon ist ein
mädchen
wie geht man damit um sie wissen diese
ja so anlaufstelle struktur auch also
meine jahre sie sind sie holen sich an
der oder genau was ich an die behörden
gewandt und die heißt es ja sind sie
sicher allein denn so daher kommt sind
sie sicher dann legen die auf das
bedeutet also man muss ein bisschen
ernst genommen werden und auch thema
aufklärung ist bei diesem thema müsste
auch ganz ganz weit vorne stehen damit
wir auch jeder von uns weiß was er
machen kann was zu machen ist in so
einem schrecklichen fall
[Musik]